right on everybody let's get into this
first story possibly one of the biggest
stories of our generation
joe biden says he has cancer thanks to
the oil industry
and then i love how they add this
but white house points to skin cancer
years ago okay okay hold on there a
minute
joe biden said he had cancer i mean the
remark initially appeared to be a
stunningly casual health announcement
during a speech about global warming in
which the president described emissions
from oil refineries near his childhood
home in cl uh claymont delaware quote
that's why i and so damn many other
people i grew up with have cancer
and why for the longest time delaware
had the highest cancer rate in the
nation
white house spokesman andrew bates
referred the post to a tweet from
washington post columnist glenn kessler
who noted that biden had non-melanoma
skin cancers removed before he took
office
i don't i don't buy it look i get it joe
biden's brain ain't all with it and
maybe he just gaffed but to have this
like
the spokesman pointed to a journalist
who pointed to a claim yeah i don't
understand why he couldn't just say
himself like this is what happened to
the president if they really did remove
the melanomas or whatever like why do
you have to refer to the washington post
you are the original source for this he
didn't have his note cards yeah okay
right yeah that's an important part
yeah he didn't know what to say
that now look look look joe biden gaffes
all the time so i'm not gonna sit here
and be like this is the one time he
wasn't guessing like no literally
everything out of his mouth is probably
gibberish nonsense so
i don't know what this means but there's
two kinds of gaffes there's the
accidental blurring of the truth gaff
and then there's the chernanasha
pressure gap yeah which one is this
gotta be the truth people don't you
don't accidentally tell people you have
cancer
anyone i've never met anyone anyone i
mean i don't know people that are
suffering from dementia and alzheimer's
i don't know a lot of them and maybe
they say things like that
if they had it they still think they
have it but then if that's an indication
of is alzheimer's or dementia that's
another problem altogether it's one or
the other either he's being honest or
he's blatantly lying to people for
sympathy which i don't think is the
case well it's a problem that it's
present tense right i didn't he's not
saying i had cancer he's saying i have
it so that's sort of a strange thing to
not take an immediately immediate strong
response from i i think
i think he's i think he slipped out the
truth maybe let me let me play this clip
i think uh let me see if it'll play
properly there we go
okay does it make me go to twitter all
right
oh here we go i always have the wrong
button clicking nice aviators joe nice
idea for lane highway
that was accessible
my mother drove us and rather than us be
able to walk and guess what
the first frost you know what was
happening
you had to put on your windshield wipers
to get literally the oil slick off the
window
that's why i had so damn many other
people i grew up have cancer
and why can't for the longest time
delaware had the highest cancer rate in
the nation
so
you know what makes me think it's
possibly him spreading out the truth is
his indignation
like his anger
you know like if it was something he had
a long time ago if he got cancer he's
talking about when he was young what he
got skin melanomas 70 years after he
left
you know what i mean so so it sounds to
me more like
this might be a he's just his brain fog
and then he just says it says it without
look i mean
if he had cancer it could explain a
whole lot it could explain literally why
he gaffs so much well i mean i think the
thing is crazy about nowadays is you
would have never thought 10 15 20 years
ago that we would have information this
readily available and they would still
be able to twist it as to and change the
narrative of what it is you know this
isn't something that's heard second or
third party this is literally broadcast
nationally internationally at the time
and then instantaneously we just say
it's something different let's think
about how crazy it is if the story is he
doesn't have cancer the president
accidentally told the world he has
cancer yikes yeah okay either his brain
is so broken he accidentally told the
world he has cancer or the dude has
cancer or what if he has cancer and he
dies in the next year or two no no it's
okay because then we get president
president commonwealth but you get that
but i'm saying at that point in time
like how do you
not let the autopsy report go i mean
it's present united states you're not
going to release that and so then you
either lie about
how he died or it comes out that you
covered up that he really did have
cancer
and now you're sitting down here and was
like hold on well you knew he had it and
you lied that he had it
and now just again the public trust just
continues to erode and fall farther and
farther we have a very important quote
here from anarchist author michael malus
oh good who said don't worry about joe
biden having cancer he is married to a
doctor
referring to the fact that first lady
jill biden uses the honorific doctor to
note her 2007 doctorate in education i
love it i don't know if but i'm pretty
sure the education thing she has isn't
like a it's like it's not the same thing
as a phd or whatever i don't know it's
something else yeah yeah i don't know
what it is and i wanted to say i worked
with old people for the first 10 years
of my career and as you get older you
still can grasp some of these concepts
but you lose your filter and it just
comes out you just blurt it out and
that's i i liked it because i got to
actually know people because there was
no like you know not there's no
um pitter-patter they're not trying to
pretend there's something they're not
they'll just tell you exactly what they
think right up front i think that's what
he's doing here it's still crazy to me
though that the stuff that he gets a
pass for like i remember you know when
president bush the the son was in office
and he wasn't a great orator how many
people just decimated him when he had a
flub here or there and some of the stuff
that trump said how many people
ridiculed him for that but biden can
just say the most off-the-wall
outlandish stuff on planet earth and
it just gets swept on the road i'll say
though now dana carvey is making fun of
him on on a kimmel did you see it
yeah he did like the oh trevor noted too
they're finally making fun of the way
biden talks his his weird man getting
real quiet and then getting real loud i
mean you should watch the dana carnegie
skit maybe we could talk about on the
after show or go into it more or even on
this show if it comes up again but like
uh that's kind of like the tide has
turned people are like okay
we got what we needed out of them now
but the successor in the wings is no
better yeah it's gonna say for a long
time the white house refused to put out
his uh they kept saying he was gonna
have his annual health exam well it was
delayed something's going on and it went
on for such a long time to a certain
point it just seems like they wanted us
to stop asking about it and
the other thing that's so strange about
his presence is how much time he spends
at his home in delaware i mean they
don't release the visitor logs for that
so we just don't know what goes on there
i mean it's total conspiracy for me to
say this but like if he is being treated
for something that's an easy place for
him to receive care in the privacy of
his own home good point
he's been retreating quite a bit i mean
i think it was something like
over 50 of the weekends that he was
president during his first year he
wasn't at the oval office he wasn't at
the white house i think the majority of
them were spent in delaware at one of
his two residents well were they doing
the i know they did a bunch of the
mock-ups of the fake like the fake oval
office when he was getting the shots and
stuff where were those at i don't know i
heard they were across the street in a
studio which is even weirder yeah yeah
what but i couldn't confirm that i don't
know where it was
uh i keep thinking about fdr franklin
delano roosevelt who had polio and he
was like [ __ ]
became crippling paralysis started to
affect him while he was in office but he
just lied to everyone didn't didn't
announce it and he put the front panel
on the desk at the oval office that's
why he's there to hide his wheelchair i
got a picture of him like holding on to
a metal railing while he's tossed
smiling and people didn't know they
didn't because it was we were i guess
the theory was we're at war we don't
want to freak out the public we want to
project strength which is like the thing
you'll be talking about y'all were
talking about on the show the other day
about how aoc getting power but she
wants to do good to get there right well
that's the slippery slope that comes
with that like you can absolutely
justify why he lied about polio right is
the betterment for the country we don't
want to seem weak the whole nine yards
but at the same time
you just justified lying to the people
about the realities that they're facing
and it's it's just it's a bad slope to
go down
what do we do
i'm just like panic
we're facing two scenarios the president
is so demented he accidentally told the
world he had cancer
now
the united the enemies of the united
states
they're not sitting there going like but
does he have cancer they're going like
either way this dude is weak
and now's our opportunity to destroy
this country do you think the cancer
quote has any change effect on that all
i mean everybody looked at him like that
right as he is i mean he shook hands
with the air
twice a couple times twice he did yeah i
wonder if maybe this is actually a 40
chess from joe biden
make your enemies think you're weak when
you're strong he read sun tzu the art of
war that's why he failed him off the
bike too that's right
it's a big ruse
he shows up these meetings and putin's
like
the weak biden and then biden goes
listen here champ he's like i'm gonna
tell you exactly what's going on and
putin's like oh no but it's strong
when do you think he'd announce that
he's not running for reelection soon
because they need to start getting ready
for the democratic primaries if that's
the case right
yeah when would that when do the
primaries start getting announced next
year okay but but usually
you know like even right now with trump
the conversations are starting to pop up
of who is it going to be
we're starting to hear the same
conversations on the democrat side yeah
hillary clinton announced that i don't
know if his official but said that she
was going to run against trump was her
so that no she didn't say that well this
is what i read on twitter i don't know
if it's all confirmed i didn't hear out
of her mouth either i thought they were
looking at ola news yeah
which is some which is nuts to me
it's nuts to me like the how he didn't
lose the recall is still i i don't grasp
that concept at all but
as bad as california is doing everybody
leaves why would that be your guy
just because it's a big state
you know
people are in a cult
to contrast him with biden he's young he
has a young family like he looks healthy
i'm not saying i'm for a new run at all
i mean you just said he was attractive
two minutes ago
he's tall so he's got that over buddha
gig is it buddha judge is that how you
pronounce it boot edge edge gig
who i don't hate you know i don't hate i
don't really hate these people but like
buddha gay buddha jed sorry buddy
whatever you say he's smaller he's like
five nine i don't know how tall he's but
he looks little yeah and so they want
people like towering presents so i think
newsome has that going for him but biden
has the towering height you know as well
it's it's nuts man i don't see how i i
still the thing that the biggest thing
that continuously shocks me about the
country is that you know you have these
people that are in office especially in
congress
for literally decades
and they just keep getting reelected
everybody knows they're not worth two
cents and we keep catching them like you
know gavin when he was how many times
was he in restaurants
when it was when it was shut down and he
had his mask off but then he just oh you
know i slipped i was taking photos and
people just forgive it and just go on i
don't i don't understand how that
happened this is a great great moral
conversation because like should
leadership lie to its subordinates
that's the question like in the military
if they know they're going into like a
suicide or a mission where it's probably
not gonna be very good do they tell the
troops that ahead of time or are they
like here's the mission you know um in
in my experience you know if you're
about ready to go
down a bad road like we know it's a bad
road you know you know that it you're
gonna get hit you know if you're gonna
run down ied alley you know you're going
down ied alley i'm sure there's probably
at some point in time we used to joke
about it when i was in like are they
sending us on because i had to go to the
iranian border twice because i did
convoy escort and we're like okay is
this how we're going to start the war
with iran they're going to send us out
there's a sacrificial lamb to get blown
up and then we'll come back and we're
going to be stopped so we would joke
about that but generally speaking my
experience has been like if you knew you
were about ready to get into it even
though the greatest oxymoron is military
intelligence they at least try to tell
you like hey like this is going to be
for real but with the president telling
the american citizens like hey here's
some strategy here's the that will get
leaked to the other humans around the
earth like your commander telling your
platoon something yeah the platoon is
not going to go tell the iraqi soldiers
what's happening so it's secure they
didn't take it a different step further
i mean a lot of times if something like
that is going to go down
i'll even give you another example of
that isn't necessarily like opsec but
like if
a service member
got killed
they would actually shut down like the
internet lines and everything there so
you couldn't tell family back home until
the military had a time to tell the
family back home
you know so they have constraints on
stuff along those lines and again like
back in war two loose lips sink ships
like that was a big thing
but when you look at this type stuff and
like whether or not he should tell the
world he has cancer right
you i think he should
you should know who's coming in next you
should know what's going on there
right and cancer isn't necessarily a
death sentence but at least we can
understand why you're shaking hands with
a glove laying in the corner i want to i
want to jump to this story it's the same
story from fox news but to make a
different point
thanks for checking out this clip from
timcast irl come hang out live monday
through friday at 8 pm eastern time
super chat we'll even answer some of
your questions if you want to check out
the after hours censored show go to
timcast.com and become a member we put
those up monday through thursday at 11
pm they're very funny not very family
friendly we'll love to see you there
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you